you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the world's biggest
jeweler says it's
switching to lab-grown diamonds to help
reduce
carbon emissions we find out if they
really are more sustainable
it's confirmed the cost of single-use
plastic bags will double
to 10p and apply to all shops
and queen guitarist brian may on why
he's involved in a campaign
to save britain's headshots
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions
we aim to take you to the heart of the
climate crisis explain
the data driving the changes that are
already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
now the world's biggest jewelry brand
has announced plans to stop
sourcing mined diamonds and switch to
lab-grown
alternatives pandora says the move will
help it become carbon neutral
by 2025 but are lab-grown gems
actually any better for the planet well
to make traditional diamonds you need a
mine transportation heavy machinery
and explosives an estimated 250 tonnes
of earth is shifted for every single
carat
of diamond mind one of the most famous
traditional mining companies de beers
uses an average of 80.3 kilowatt hours
per carat but lab made diamonds are
energy intensive
because of the amount of power that they
use now making them needs
carbon a source of energy and sometimes
gas
now an average synthetic diamond takes
250 kilowatt
hours per carat grown far more than four
traditional gems
the emissions depend on where the
electricity comes from
between 50 and 60 of synthetic diamonds
are made in china
where coal-fired power stations are the
main energy source and that results in
205 kilograms of carbon dioxide
equivalent per polished carrot however
if the power was from natural gas it
would be 122 kilograms per carat
for solar power 12 kilograms hydropower
is 6
kilos of greenhouse gases and if the
power comes from wind
there's only three kilograms of harmful
emissions per
lab grown diamond carrot well with me
now is dale vince the founder of sky
diamond a company which says it's
tackling the climate crisis by creating
beautiful ethical diamonds
using green technology with no carbon
footprint so welcome to you
as we heard there dale vince creating
diamonds in a lab uses a huge amount of
power so how do you make sure that the
process is carbon neutral
well our process uh just has uh
four simple ingredients we use the rain
and the sun
sorry if we use the wind and the sun to
make energy to power our process we
capture rain and we split that to make
hydrogen
and we take carbon directly from the
atmosphere which is the core ingredient
the only ingredient really the diamond
in fact so the winter sun the rain and
carbon from the atmosphere that's all we
use so our process is not carbon neutral
or
or carbon zero it's carbon negative we
embed
carbon from the atmosphere into our
stones we've commissioned a report by
imperial college it's an independent one
the first
in the world and that shows 1100 tons of
rock have to be dug to make a single
carat of stone
and our own energy footprint is 40 units
of electricity not 250 but 40. that's
like
three days typical household use in
britain
i guess how green a lab-grown diamond is
depends on the kind of powder you use if
it's fossil fuels it's going to cause
problems
to mine 1100 tons of stone you have to
use a lot of fossil fuels i think this
is a myth
from the mining industry it's a
defensive measure they put out these
reports a few years ago i think the
numbers are very
unreliable um you know we're using
machines that are available in the world
today to make our stones that's not
special it is only 40 units of
electricity
and um you know by comparison the uh
greenhouse gas emissions for
for a carrot of mine stone is half a ton
and the carbon footprint is a hundred
kilograms you know
these are um these are this is data from
imperial college who've
you know put a lot of time into this to
get an independent view of the mind
industry
and um you know it's about time we kind
of shine a light on this because there's
a lot said about
lab grown stones having a high energy
content and i think it's not true
and certainly in our experience it's
absolutely not true
and what about the the end product can
you tell the difference between a lab
grown diamond
and one that's traditionally mined
if you're in a lab and you stick it
under a microscope you can see a
difference and the difference
is that their lab growth stone is more
perfect
but if you're a jeweler or a member of
the public somebody looking at a piece
of jewelry absolutely you can't tell
they're chemically identical
and almost molecularly identical but the
lab grown is slightly more perfect
dale vince very interesting to talk to
you thanks very much indeed
now carbon dioxide emissions from fossil
fuel combustion in the eu
dropped 10 last year eurostat the eu
statistical office found that emissions
fell in
all of the eu's 27 member states
compared with 2019 as governments
imposed lockdowns
due to covert 19. and here on our data
dashboard you can see
how co2 emissions around the world are
ticking up and that of course has an
impact on this
number here this is human-induced global
warming that's how much our planet
has warmed since the industrial
revolution
and then up here you can see the
real-time
power mix in great britain and around 47
of our electricity is currently coming
from fossil fuels 34
from renewable sources and 19 there from
nuclear and you can see a more detailed
breakdown of the real-time power makes
including just how much electricity is
coming from sources including wind and
solar
anytime you like just head to our
website skynews.com
climate now let's take a look at some of
those other climate news now
and every household in england will
receive separate
weekly food collections from 2023
to help people recycle their waste it's
part of plans by the government to reach
their target of eliminating
all avoidable waste by 2050. ministers
are also considering
free garden waste collections which
could save homeowners
over a hundred million pounds a year in
charges
[Applause]
the national trust is reconstructing a
19th century parkland in norfolk using
aerial photos taken by the raf after the
second world
war work is already underway at oxbra
hall to restore 175 of the original
400 acres of woodland making it one of
the largest habitats the charity has
ever created
the conservation team hope it'll make
the area more resilient to climate
change
and biologists in france are playing
their very own game of where's wally
forget the stripey t-shirt and bobble
hat wally the gray whale has been
spotted in the mediterranean
thousands of miles from his natural
habitat in the pacific ocean
experts think he accidentally swam into
the atlantic ocean
after global warming melted ice and
opened up a route through
now the price of plastic bags in england
is being doubled to
10 pence all businesses including corner
shops will have to apply the charge
from the 21st of may previously only
retailers with more than 250
employees were required to do so so the
five pence charge was introduced in
england
in 2015. since then their use has fallen
by
95 the average shopper
now only buys four single-use plastic
bags a year
and that's compared with 140 in 2014.
the government says it hopes a new cost
will reduce the use of plastic bags by
up to 80 percent
in small and medium-sized shops
well campaigner lizzie carr founded the
group planet patrol
and thinks the tempe charge doesn't go
far enough
she's calling for a total ban on plastic
bags including
bags for life one major retailer
actually reported a two thousand
seven hundred and forty percent increase
in back for life sales over that four
year
levy period so these figures show that
people really aren't deterred by a
charge we need to see
more transparent reporting that's across
all retailers
large and small and we need to see this
fed back to the general public more
accurately and not
completely emitting bag for life sales
which we know have skyrocketed
now they're one of britain's most
recognizable and well-loved
mammals but hedgehogs are vulnerable to
extinction in the uk
gardens with decking and artificial turf
a loss of natural habitat
and even climate change are all posing a
threat to the spiny creatures
well in an effort to help a campaign is
aiming to create britain's first
hedgehog friendly borough school
children in surrey heath are being given
everything they need to create a safe
haven for the endangered
mammal well queen guitarist brian may is
part of the campaign and he joins me now
brian may thanks so much for talking to
us
tell us a little bit more about this
campaign you've got going in schools
in that area what are you teaching the
children and what do you want to achieve
well children are wonderful actually
because they do get it immediately
and we're very much in the schools in
surrey heath and they're helping us do
a survey a census of hedgehogs in the
area and it gets them into this feeling
that
these animals are precious and that
they're threatened and they are the next
generation who will have to look after
them
i mean we do make a big noise about uh
how people treat their
their their wildlife population in other
countries but we're really not doing a
very good job in this country
and hedgehogs are massively in decline
from about 30 million to under 1 million
now
it's a very serious thing and it's not
just they're cute creatures i mean these
are the
the wildlife of britain and if you make
your
your country your countryside and your
gardens etc
friendly to hedgehogs then they'll be
friendly to all the wild animals that we
have in britain so it's a very very
serious cause
as the habitat gets eaten up more and
more by housing and urbanization
concrete
i mean it's clear that you're passionate
about conservation you're passionate
about the environment and have been for
years i just want to get your view
on musicians touring because i know
coldplay for example decided not to tour
their album just over a year ago
because of the the carbon footprint
involved is that something that queen
would ever consider doing
well we have considered it yes we've
postponed our touring twice now so we're
now due to go out next may and june
and we're very much looking at lessening
our carbon footprint yeah i think people
will still have to travel if you would
if you if you play music you have to get
to people somehow it's not good enough
just to be on zoom or
or tv or the internet or whatever you
have to make personal contact but
yes you can be a lot more careful about
how much energy you use how much
pollution you create
what your carbon um impression is
so yes we're looking at it and we'll do
the best we can we already did actually
on the last tour we did
um which was all around um southeast
asia
we cut down the amount of trucks that we
use to about half so
it's it it's there it's coming brian may
thanks very much indeed
that's it for today's show but you can
get your climate fix over the weekend
with our podcast
on this week's episode we're talking
tipping points and how it's not too late
to save the planet that's on climate
cast and it's available wherever you
normally get your podcast from
and on our weekly digital show this week
sky correspondent siobhan robbins tells
us the behind the scenes story
of thailand's fight against toxic
wildfires
that's available on sky news social
channels our app and our website
thanks for watching and see you next
week
[Music]
you